the host is directed by Andrew Niccol
produced by Stephenie Meyer adapted from
her book the writer of the Twilight
series this film stars wait for it
sheersha Ronan I practiced that max
irons William Hurt and Diane Kruger this
film is basically about an alien race
that has taken over earth
now these aliens are able to take over
human bodies and start to control them
and this alien race is basically perfect
they don't steal they don't lie
they don't cheat they don't believe in
violence and they have no real concept
of physical attraction they know what it
is they just don't submit to it and when
a young girl played by sheersha Ronan is
taken over by one of these aliens her
eyes changed colors and now all the
humans the remaining resistance are
against her after this alien host has
taken over her body this host starts to
realize that she can hear the original
girl's voice still in her head telling
her what to do and when she encounters
people that she used to know including
her long-lost love things get weird now
I try not to be one of those guys that
looks at a film and looks at the people
involved and automatically thinks this
is going to be horrible I like to think
that in some way people who make movies
do actually have a passion for film and
they want to make something that's going
to inspire people and something that's
important and something that's or at
least just fun and entertaining I like
to think that despite the fact that a
certain person may have a continued
string of crap that this one just might
be the one that's good now the director
of this movie andrew niccol has been
involved in good films in the past he
made Gattaca he was the writer of The
Truman Show he's made good films
Stephenie Meyer who wrote the original
book and produced this film has not
she's been involved with all the
Twilight films so the best way that I
can describe how I feel by this movie is
by telling you the fact that I walked
out of this film like two hours ago and
I was just sitting over there listening
to some music and I went oh yeah I saw
the hosts today I get just I gone just
gone for my mind the host is a stale
boring unintentionally funny film with
so many romantic cliches that it is just
absurd has all the Stephenie Meyer
cliches number
love triangle guess what it's in there
number two the love that you want but
you can't have because of some sort of
supernatural reason it's in there number
three some entity of some kind that
would rather be another creature species
or race in Twilight it was Bella wanting
to be a vampire in this film it's the
alien wanting to not be like all of her
other aliens and possibly wanting to be
more like a human this film is so
riddled with the Stephenie Meyer
checklist it is crazy but it's not just
that the film is so boring it really is
boring at movies like two hours and five
minutes long but the way Andrew Niccol
directed this movie some of the shots
look okay but for the most part it's so
stagnant the shots are all completely
static they rarely ever move there's no
flow or interesting quality to the way
he directs there's zero style as I
mentioned earlier there's a lot of
unintentional hilarity in this movie in
particular one scene in which one guy
from the love triangle and the main girl
are sitting on a mountaintop the guy
looks at her and goes I like you
I like you
yeah
oh this is a movie I will give the movie
this there's one good quality I found in
this movie that of sheersha Ronan she is
a talented actress and she is really
honestly giving a lot to this movie she
really is doing a lot with her
performance this movie 100% does not
deserve the performance she's trying to
give it's completely forgettable in
every way and it's a poor attempt at
trying to just take the Twilight formula
and switch it around into something else
Twilight at least had like this guilty
pleasure esque vibe to it where I could
watch it and be like this is so stupid
but it's so stupid that I'm laughing
right now like this movie is so bad but
they're trying to make like a great film
and this is just not worthy and so
you're just sitting there like wow this
is just so bad that it's bad I'm gonna
give the host a d-minus purely because I
thought sure sure Ronan was good in the
film yeah don't don't watch it just
don't it's not good
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck menage
[Music]
you